[موسيقى]
انا سن ابو مدان بنت غزه كل الفخر اني انا
بنت غزه اعلاميه
فلسطينيه انا حابه اوصل صوت غزه للعالم
وانا بصور الفيديو ممكن استشهد قبل ما يجي
الفيدي قبل ما يوصلكم
الفيديو فش لا نت ولا ميه ولا كهرب ولا كل
مقومات الحياه غزه تحت حصار غزه فيش فيها
مقومات الحياه احنا وصلنا لمرحله في غزه
ما حدش بيقدر يتخيلها الصحفيين استهدفوه
عشان ما نقدر نوصل صوتنا للعالم سيارات
الاسعاف استهدفوه اللي فيها الجرحه
والمصابين الجرحى بالمستشفيات كثار بدنا
مساعدات طبيه عشان نقدر اللي ظل على قيد
الحياه نساعده انه يعيش
الشهداء من كثر ما في شهداء عنا لاجات
الموضى بطلت توسعهم في خيمه قدام المستشفى
بحطوا فيها الشهيد اطفال ماتوا طيب هم
الاطفال شو عملوا اعملوا
ستهدف البنايات على رس ساكنيها عيل انمسحت
من السجل المدني احنا اهل غزه كلنا على
نفس واحد بنحكي نموت وتحيا القضيه حنظل في
غزه مش ح نتزحزح منها ها ارضنا مش حنطلع
منها ونكبه 48 مش حترجع تاني وينكم
عرب